Shure: 老班长
Shure: Hey, old squad leader.
Shure: 老板找什么啊
Shure: Boss, what are you looking for?
Jake:手机
Jake: My phone.
Shure: 啊你怎么没在楼下洗
Shure: Ah, why didn't you wash downstairs?
Jake:因为上面风水比较好
Jake: Because the feng shui is better up here.
Jake:在这洗澡了
Jake: I'm taking a shower here.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 这边可以边洗澡边看着对面
Shure: You can shower here and watch the opposite side.
Shure: 是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Right? Hahaha.
Shure: 还是可以这么洗是吗
Shure: You can still shower like this, right?
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 念什么
Shure: What are you reciting?
其他人：电池发货了
Other: The batteries have been shipped.
Shure: 什么发货了
Shure: What's been shipped?
其他人：电池
Other: The batteries.
Shure: 别说我会买
Shure: Don't say it, I'll buy it.
Shure: 下次见到这种直接分享给妈妈好吗
Shure: Next time you see something like this, just share it with mom, okay?
其他人：分享不了
Other: Can't share.
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
其他人：我又没有微信
Other: I don't have WeChat.
Shure: 没事不急
Shure: It's okay, no rush.
其他人：好可爱
Other: So cute.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
其他人：你看看热靴热靴盖
Other: Look, it's a hot shoe cover.
Shure: 什么盖
Shure: A cover for what?
其他人： 呃就是相机顶部接闪光灯啊啊啊
Other: Uh, it's for the top of the camera where you attach the flash.
其他人：叫热靴一个卡口
Other: It's called a hot shoe adapter.
Shure: 嗯等一下
Shure: Hmm, wait a second.
其他人：一个消火器的转接线
Other: An adapter cable for a fire extinguisher.
其他人：是不是好漂亮
Other: Isn't it beautiful?
Shure: 可惜我是鼓手哈哈哈
Shure: Too bad I'm a drummer. Hahaha.
Shure: 不他是
Shure: No, he is.
其他人：306020
Other: 306020.
Shure: 因为你看啊
Shure: Because look,
Shure: 它是两个效果器之间的这种
Shure: it's between two effect pedals.
Shure: 然后它是粘到一个板板上吗
Shure: And it's stuck onto a board, right?
其他人：哦那我理解了我本来以为是
Other: Oh, I understand now. I originally thought it was...
Shure: 什么电源线那种是吗
Shure: What kind of power cable is it?
其他人：对啊
Others: Yeah.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 这也是那个卡扣
Shure: This is also that clip.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure: 你怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with you?
其他人：手表保护壳
Others: Watch case.
其他人：会发光
Others: It glows.
Shure: 你早上刷一些这些电子小垃圾是吧
Shure: You scroll through these electronic gadgets in the morning, huh?
其他人：因为我淘宝推荐只有这些东西
Others: Because Taobao only recommends these things to me.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 这个三脚架蛮好的
Shure: This tripod is pretty good.
Shure: 他这个这个阻尼特别的
Shure: The damping on this one is special.
Shure: 而且你感受一下这的阻尼
Shure: And you can feel the weight here.
Shure: 你特别的就是他有一个小的小的惯性
Shure: What's special is that it has a bit of inertia.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
其他人： 你哦我的也有啊
Others: Oh, mine has it too.
Shure: 这个这个阻尼感好好
Shure: The damping feel is really good.
Jake:奥是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很棒怎么穿校服了
Shure: Awesome, why are you wearing a school uniform?
Shure: 这啊这个
Shure: This, uh, this.
其他人：呃线给错了
Others: Uh, the cable is wrong.
Shure: 哦应该问题不大
Shure: Oh, it shouldn't be a big problem.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:呃给你换一下
Jake: Uh, let me change it for you.
Shure: 换一下对
Shure: Change it, yeah.
Jake:吃什么
Jake: What to eat?
Shure: 吃什么
Shure: What to eat?
其他人：早饭还是午饭
Others: Breakfast or lunch?
Jake:这是午饭
Jake: This is lunch.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Jake:午饭吃什么
Jake: What to eat for lunch?
Shure: 我们的饭不能被定义
Shure: Our meals can't be defined.
Shure: 别盲盒了
Shure: No more blind boxes.
Shure: 什么选择
Shure: What are the options?
Shure: 第六家就是
Shure: The sixth one is...
Shure: 哈哈别别搞这个
Shure: Haha, don't mess with that.
Shure: 我想想你等我想想
Shure: Let me think, wait, let me think.
Shure: 你别急
Shure: Don't panic.
Shure: 我害怕了
Shure: I'm scared now.
Jake:要不上门口吃
Jake: How about we eat at the entrance?
Shure: 门口是什么啊
Shure: What's at the entrance?
Shure: 就是那边啊
Shure: It's just over there.
Shure: 不是不行
Shure: It's not impossible.
Shure: 咱们还没有外出吃过早餐
Shure: We haven't had breakfast outside yet.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:这可以饿着吃
Jake: You can eat while hungry.
Shure: 都可以
Shure: Anything works.
Shure: 看大家什么时候醒吧
Shure: Let's see when everyone wakes up.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:咱还有面包
Jake: We still have bread.
Shure: 还有俩安格斯厚牛堡呢
Shure: And two Angus beef burgers.
Shure: 哎一会给给老板叮一下子
Shure: Hey, let's heat one up for the boss later.
Shure: 然后老板先吃
Shure: And let the boss eat first.
Shure: 老老板如果不死我就吃另一个
Shure: If the boss doesn't die, I'll eat the other one.
其他人：你要不要这个
Others: Do you want this?
Shure: 什么等一下
Shure: What? Wait a second.
Shure: 哎有2.3的误差是吗
Shure: Hey, there's a 2.3 discrepancy, right?
其他人：一个很漂亮的手机杯
Others: A very beautiful phone cup.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：你天天摔什么
Others: Why do you keep dropping things?
Shure: 谁天天摔
Shure: Who keeps dropping things?
Shure: 我手机从来不摔
Shure: I never drop my phone.
Shure: 那这个是干嘛的哦
Shure: What's this for?
Shure: 这是固定哦
Shure: It's fixed in place, right?
其他人：他几个就是固定了相机的快装板
Others: Yeah, it's a quick release plate for fixing the camera.
其他人：然后调屏
Others: Then you adjust the screen.
其他人：就是这个样子
Others: That's how it works.
其他人：调平然后横向的扭
Others: Adjust it horizontally and it can swivel this way.
其他人：还有可以这么反转
Others: It can also flip like this.
其他人：你看它正常
Others: See, it's normal.
其他人：对这个是固定这个位置的
Others: Yeah, it's fixed in this position.
其他人：它是这个卡扣可以让它这么转
Others: This clip allows it to turn like this.
其他人：就是一个关节状的东西
Others: It's like a joint mechanism.
Shure: 行拿个杯子
Shure: Alright, grab a cup.
Shure: 那有一个给刷了
Shure: There's one that's already been cleaned.
Shure: 他都看到你了
Shure: He's already seen you.
Shure: 这肯定是他昨天晚上捣那些葡萄的
Shure: This must be from the grapes he was messing with last night.
Shure: 那个
Shure: That
Shure: 刷出去
Shure: Swipe it out
Shure: 唉
Shure: Hey
Shure: 怎么逼着少爷伺候人呢
Shure: How can you force the young master to serve people?
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's wrong?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
其他人：没币啊
Others: No coins?
Shure: 什么没币
Shure: What do you mean no coins?
Shure: 不是逼着上来伺候人吗啊
Shure: Weren't you forcing me to come up and serve people?
Shure: 是没币
Shure: So, no coins?
Shure: 你要干嘛
Shure: What do you want to do?
Shure: 喂怎么了
Shure: Hey, what's up?
Shure: 嗯没有
Shure: Hmm, nothing.
Shure: 今天最后一天
Shure: Today's the last day.
Shure: 这嗯
Shure: This, hmm
Shure: 没啥事
Shure: Nothing much.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 很少基本可以没有
Shure: Very rarely, almost never.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 咱忙着呢那时候
Shure: We were busy then.
Shure: 烫烫烫嗯
Shure: Hot, hot, hot, hmm
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 对啊供吃供住供喝供玩咖
Shure: Yeah, we provide food, accommodation, drinks, and entertainment, coffee too.
Shure: 咖啡豆都公款
Shure: Coffee beans are all on company expenses.